and real quick wrestling question it
looks like you're gonna have Daniel
Bryan at SummerSlam does it it looks to
me like that watch the show would you be
happy with that SummerSlam answer I said
listen I don't know if Daniel Bryan is
isre signing with WWE or not so the fact
is I was a little upset with by the fact
that I was taken from Monday Night Raw
which I was doing very very well at now
and I was brought to SmackDown life
because Daniel Bryan asked the general
manager page for me to come over there
then after two months Daniel Bryan has
done nothing to me
zero hasn't said a word has done nothing
I've beat him in a gauntlet match
already and if anything I was I'm a
little upset that nothing has happened
right so so yeah and now all of a sudden
he might not resign he wants me a parent
time whenever dan and I fight for my
dreams yadda yadda yadda and and so yeah
I mean I I wouldn't mind having him at
SummerSlam to basically get him out of
WWE once and for all
one more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM f
[Music]